all right let's get right into your
emails you can email us info
davidpakman.com
every friday we take a look through the
mailbag so to speak it's really more of
an internet folder but it still seems
like we call it a mailbag i don't know
why it doesn't make any sense um and
emails of all sorts are featured you can
email info davidpakman.com with your
thoughts about the show politics
questions whatever the case may be
so many meaty and substantive emails
this week let's start uh one email
from one of our viewers
who is a neurologist making a very
important point
last week you had a caller that
mentioned nurses talking about how the
covet vaccine might cause individuals to
misinterpret their symptoms it seems
this discussion of the nurses might be a
misinterpretation of an actual report
there is a report that there are quote
functional neurological disorders after
the vaccine
i am a neurologist functional
neurological disorder is the medical
term for what used to be called
psychogenic symptoms in other words
folks are reporting symptoms that are
not of medical origin after their
vaccines below is a summary of the
report from medscape happy to interpret
but as a brief summary there are a
number of neurological examination
tricks that neurologists use to identify
psychogenic versus neurological weakness
one of these is the hoover sign
mentioned below yeah so this this is a
really important thing
a lot of the time
people will not understand
the difference between a symptom
and
an actual physiological side effect of a
medication
and
for example
you can have
a headache after a vaccine or after a
medication or after working out or
whatever
it's not that the headache isn't real
but there may not be
a physiological cause for that
but it doesn't make the symptom any less
real and there's a lot of different
terms that are sometimes applied here in
different disciplines sometimes people
talk about psychosomatic we don't even
need to go into that as our viewer here
is saying we're talking about when we
say functional neurological disorder if
you don't know what that means you're
like whoa that's a the vaccine causes a
functional neurological disorder as is
being pointed out that means there's a
symptom
which we don't believe to actually be
caused
by
something going on neurologically and
this applies in many other areas of
medicine as well very important point
and you can read more about it if that's
interesting to you
next email comes from cody
cody says hello david i'm having trouble
dealing with the fact that some members
of my family have stated they will never
get the vaccine especially my brother
who's a local business owner and comes
into contact with a good deal of our
community i've presented them with the
information on the vaccine how it's fda
approved how 99 percent of deaths and 97
percent of hospitalizations are from the
unvaccinated and info on mrna vaccines
and nothing is getting through to them i
often get the rebuttal that it's my body
my choice but when i explain it isn't
just them they are affecting it's
everyone around them
friends family in our community they
shrug it off and suggest those people
should stay at home then
do you have any suggestions on a
different approach to this i appreciate
your time and enjoy your content keep up
the good work listen i am not pretending
to have solutions here uh sometimes
knowing someone who gets very sick or
dies
is the only thing that will change the
minds of some of these people even then
sometimes that won't change their minds
so i don't have advice sadly other than
advice for you which is at a certain
point you might decide for your own
sanity this is a personal decision that
you've had enough
and you're not going to try to convince
them anymore
but maybe you decide you can't have them
in your lives that's not a suggestion
and i've not decided that with anybody
but
you might reach a point where you say
this is too much the stress of this is
too much
and for safety and sanity i'm opting out
of this relationship or you might say
i'm just going to try to keep going
because it's so important to me
or you might try a different approach i
don't know i wish i had an answer about
what the right way to convince these
people what the most effective way would
be
to convince these folks
next email today is from michael
michael says hi i watch the show from
the uk most days find them entertaining
and informative nevertheless i cringed
oh no
i cringed during an article when you
repeatedly said a coveted number that
had tripled had increased by 300 percent
tripling means an increase of 200
percent just as doubling would be a 100
increase careful with the maths
and keep up the good work
i cringed when i realized i made this
mathematical mistake
i make every effort to be accurate and
precise with the audience
i appreciate the correction from michael
and when i said the other day coveted
cases are up 300 percent and deaths are
up 70
300 percent
is a quadrupling
whereas the 70 increase in deaths is
almost a doubling okay apologies
and always appreciate the corrections
skye wrote in
sky says david my in-laws are both major
trump supporters
as well as deep into conspiracies my
husband and his mother regularly have
debates and recently had one that took
an interesting turn they were talking
about vaccines and in his desperation to
get her to see reason he suggested that
all the misinformation was a liberal
conspiracy
to eliminate all the anti-vaxx
conservatives in order to win elections
he also posed the question of how many
liberals have died due to covid
and asked her to name one she could not
i found this strategy interesting and
thought you might as well
do do we have to sink so low as to
basically trick anti-vaxxers into
getting the vaccine at this point would
it be effective or damaging in the long
term i've talked about this before
i think that there would be
i don't know if we would call them scams
there would be things joe biden could
say and do
that would make the right go and get
vaccinated for example imagine if joe
biden announced like of course he would
never do it it would never be legal
but imagine if joe biden announced
because of all of the things that these
red state governors are doing
after october 1st conservatives and
republicans will no longer be allowed to
get the vaccine it's like it's so
obviously impossible legally and
logistic like it would never happen but
the point is
i am convinced
that if trumpists conservatives
republicans whoever is in the anti-vaxx
group
if they came to believe
that they were not going to be allowed
to get the vaccine because of their
political views millions of them would
run out
and get the vaccine there's no question
about it if a theory hypothesis rumor
started to spread
that the left doesn't want conservatives
to get vaccinated
so that they die
i think there is no doubt that if it was
believed if it was believed of course if
it was believed
that a ton of these right-wingers would
go out and try to get vaccinated now is
it damaging in the long term yeah i mean
if if if joe biden did something like
that even if it worked i do think in the
long term it would be damaging because
it would further foment the idea that
the government is lying to you and you
can't trust the government to do
anything and on and on and on so i'm not
recommending it i don't think it would
be a good long-term play
but it would sure as hell work uh with
some of these uh some some of these
right-wingers so interesting that the
conversation went that way spencer wrote
to me
spencer said i am seeing studies
suggesting that teenage boys are far
more likely to suffer from myocarditis
related to the vaccine than to end up in
the hospital from covid have you heard
anything backing this claim up i'm only
able to find a few articles talking
about it yeah i read a study this
morning about it it's not true
um in fact there there was a study that
was going to look at myocarditis in
teenage boys
and it had like a sample of nine million
vaccinated teenage boys
and like none of them got it
or or at least none of them got it badly
enough to have to be hospitalized or
something like that uh no the the
evidence i've seen is that
the vaccine is safer than kovid at every
age group at every age group very
important because there are some who
will say if you are of a certain age
it actually makes less sense to get the
vaccine but from what i've seen is that
at every age group for just about every
medical condition
you are better off with the vaccine and
its possible side effects than you are
getting covered big picture
statistically speaking
lastly today this one's a doozy guys
this is from jj
this stuff is constantly coming into my
email it's just dumping in all the time
here is someone who has
somehow ended up believing really
incorrect things about covid and
vaccination
jj says david sir no they didn't say sir
how about the adults unable to get the
real
vaccines also
the delta virus thing a complete lie
covid sext when and how
no mutations right there
the proof needed
it's so sad
that this is going on in our country
i i don't know what else to say you know
how about the adults unable to get the
real vaccines i think this is
some allusion to fake vaccines i don't i
don't know
the delta virus thing is a complete lie
um you know we we sequence the virus we
know what percentage of cases are delta
we saw mew peaked in july and then has
come down
at some point if if someone's going to
say
this is an apple and you're going to say
it's not an apple it's a fake apple and
it's imaginary
at some point you can't convince them
covet sext
i don't know or do viruses have have sex
i did i didn't think so i don't maybe
they do i don't think it matters
um
incoherent and unfortunately really
really unfortunately
a lot of people i don't even know what
that belief i don't even know what
they're saying
but i know a lot of people believe stuff
like that
because they email me all the time we're
gonna have real trouble getting out of
this pandemic
if that type of stuff
remains as prevalent as it is we'll
track whether vaccinations go up with
the latest requirements and initiatives
from joe biden we will track all of it
we've got a great bonus show for you
today please become a member really
folks please become a member sign up at
joinpacman.com we do this show every day
but then we do an extra show called the
bonus show every day and you can get
instant access to it if you become a
member at joinpakman.com
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits take the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get 50 off your first
month when you go to steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video